the applegate river lodge is located in
beautiful applegate oregon the lodge is
nestled amongst gorgeous rivers lush
vineyards and boasts some of the north
west's most stunning views
owners joanna and richard davis built
the lodge 22 years ago richard actually
designed the lodge and built it having
that much workload a stress was just
unbearable once this labor of love was
completed richard decided it was time to
take a break and relax
for 20 years
the couple got divorced so richard now
lives on site in a hut next to the main
lodge
my giver name was richard but at this
stage of my life i just go by paw butt
the applegate river lodge it's been a
way of life here for my family for about
22 years right now my duties are making
sure that the energy that was
given to me to stuart is here on the
property at all times
and yeah it's pot
let me grab my guitar
where is my good time while richard is
looking for his guitar back on earth his
ex-wife joanna is desperately looking
for the money to keep the lodge's doors
open we could easily lose anywhere from
five to fifteen thousand dollars a month
just because of lack of business
what's going on see we've got new
reservations coming up what are you
doing
i'm just screwing her off
i actually live in my motor home i
rented my house out
did you need something no i'm just
hanging out i don't see the applicator
river lives as a business never have
never will
[Music]
all the pressure of running the lodge
falls on joanna's shoulders she had high
hopes her two sons duke and dusty would
take charge of the business i just
totally [ __ ] disagree with what
you're doing should be none of your
concerns there's a big window you don't
have anything to do with this goddamn
restaurant but their constant fighting
has gotten in the way my brother and i
have a rocky relationship
and
led to fistfights and all sorts of
arguments the brothers refused to work
together so dusty runs the restaurant
and bar as a separate business i'll grab
your menu and we can get you something
else with his girlfriend i'm head chef
tammy way too much olive oil on them
they turn them back while duke and his
wife melissa use the hotel's lobby as a
concert venue organizing regular music
nights how's everybody feeling tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
dusty's a lot more into deadlines and
numbers
and i'm a lot more into feelings and
ideas and concepts
a lot of people say there's too much
past smoking too much music too much of
this and too much of that too much fun
that's not my take on it
[Music]
and if that's not enough of a headache
for guests trying to sleep
richard holds after hours jam sessions
what time is it
111.
i have had to comp some rooms here at
the lodge it was too noisy for them or
they didn't think the room was clean
enough ooh
there's spiderwebs all over it
so gross
i've had to cop quite a few rooms
unsurprisingly the inn is hemorrhaging
money dragged down by a co-owner who
doesn't treat the lodge as a business
and two fighting sons
if i can't get this family working
together their business is doomed
this lodge is my life it's a legacy to
carry on through generations but the
family is so dysfunctional that gordon's
just gonna say you know what i can't fix
you guys
we have to save the business we have to
save our family
i think gordon's our
only hope
my first time in oregon
beautiful countryside
i'm on the way to the applegate river
lodge
now if they've got a lodge here and
they're not making a fortune they must
be doing something seriously wrong
that is beautiful my goodness me
what's that dump and what's that smell
[Music]
are you ready to go back to sleep true
[Music]
costly
[Music]
wow
hello
it is huge
but it's so empty
where's all the furniture and where is
everybody am i too late
wow
press the button for the buzz to summon
a human with answers you are kidding me
just relax
i gotta do exactly what i'm doing
hello
[Music]
it's like this place hasn't been
finished off inside
hello
hello
where are the guests supposed to sit
[Music]
hey hey hello what are you doing
i thought you'd gone no i was uh just
hanging out uh sorry i didn't catch your
first name richard richards but around
here they're gonna call me papa
pogba paw pat puppets we're just
battling all of us around around here
do you normally run from desk this belt
is to my room okay and then when music
starts coming i turn it over music
the music program we're gonna do tonight
uh so there's a music there's a band
playing tonight yes
and then we'll probably jam out later
okay in the butt hut
what what is the butt just help me would
you like to see the butthead
uh i'd love to see the butt happy okay
yeah this is where you run the reception
from the bar
[Music]
wow this is the butthole this is where
me and troopy hang out
get up
smell what is that smell
incense they're right here incense that
is a strong [ __ ] incense yeah jesus
yeah but that doesn't smell like the
smell i've just smelled yeah it's herbs
it's a medicinal herb i love herbs
especially the freshness of them you can
use it for cooking if you want to do a
really nice fettuccine okay
what's it like this is yeah it's like a
basil
wow
it has a nice smell to it
[ __ ] me
that's definitely not basil
is this cannabis
yes
so we smoke by it that's what i could
smell the minute i came in here yeah
what do you want me to do is this legal
here yes i use a medicinal herb
before you put your hands back in that
cookie jar do you mind if i see my room
it's a get a bit late oh oh ah i'm not
i'm done for a while okay you're done
yeah
you know how do i get to the room i'll
show you
this is the first the owner of this
lodge is as high as a kite wow look at
this place he probably hasn't even
noticed the place has no furniture
this is the cattleman room kettleman
room thank you yeah
it smells like cattle in here wow
what happened to the carpet the dog have
an accident you know we party a lot here
so you're gonna have liquor who knows
what's on these carpets right
what's that
that's just bugs a bugs bloody hell yeah
oh
i'm a crispy daddy long leg
that's disgusting
and this is your view out here
no i didn't notice the view because of
the carpet my god what a stunning
location it's paradise
it truly is
yeah i'll say i mean this place is
stunning
shame is so filthy richard
so the bedroom's up here right right
what in the hell has happened to this
carpet i haven't been up there in a
while there's more stains on this carpet
than inside hugh hefner's [ __ ] wife
oh yeah i told you they party in here no
but how i mean how many come look at
this car every room's got those stains
on them you know and what about the
cover on the bed when was that from
1970. you have talked to joanna about
that john that's your wife ex-wife
excellent oh damn yeah damn yeah she
wants to be a business
where she should be it's not a business
to me
don't ask me finances because i would be
lying if i told you i knew anything i
don't let's catch up later i'm gonna
pack my bags okay okay uh thanks for the
update this place is disgusting
and it's hardly surprising seeing that
the owner doesn't see it as a business i
need some fresh air he clearly doesn't
care about paying guests
kids don't do drugs you'll end up like
that
i've just arrived at oregon's applegate
river lodge
hello the hotel lobby has no furniture
it is so bearing here the rooms are
disgusting
it's like a basil and i've discovered
one of the owners is a carefree hippie
it's not a business to me
richard says his ex-wife is the
businesswoman here i hope she has a
better head on her shoulders hello
joanna gord nice to see you nice to meet
you so
your joiner was married to richard yes
you deserve a medal
um and what do you do well let's see i
check people in i do the banking
mean i'm the only one in the family
that's ever you know taken care of the
books and made sure that the mortgage
payment was paid why is it all on your
shoulders you just sound like the only
one who's actually in control of this
i'm the only one
no he's never even looked at the
checkbook
i'm really tired i'm getting tired of
holding everything up and it's getting
old driving through here those vineyards
the mountains i mean you must be making
a fortune
well you know i'm
well i own 990 000 on this and we lose
from five to fifteen thousand dollars a
month this is crazy yeah but how can the
business not be in profit uh that's my i
don't know i don't understand no that's
that's what i need you for i honestly
having seen the lobby and my bedroom
yeah i can see why the hotel might be
struggling but surely the restaurant
must be making money with that view on
the river like that well the restaurant
is run by dusty my younger son okay and
then duke and his wife run the music end
of the business okay what percentage of
profits do you get none
bloody hell it sounds nuts i know it
sounds just crazy
wow i mean look at this place
it's like a
missed opportunity beyond belief i mean
that's what everybody tells me everybody
says you got a gold mine here and i go
well so far i haven't found the gold
[Music]
this place is a patch of heaven
so i'm shocked to hear it's not making
money
i can't wait to hear why joanna's sons
aren't contributing to the lodge's
finances
i see him first name is melissa melissa
gordon nice to see you too
well hello how are you likewise my
pleasure good to see you duke right yeah
so this is set up for the concert yeah i
run the sound okay mixing yeah yeah okay
great and how much did you get in
it's fifteen fifteen dollars fifteen
dollars yeah so out of that fifteen
dollars charge how much goes to money
none none well
let's have a quick word outside
[Music]
the place has got a million dollars debt
yeah i know and it's and
and i've been sitting waiting and i i
can i can relate
i think i know what's going on here when
was the last time i had a smoke
way earlier this afternoon
20 minutes ago no no no no this morning
this
morning
it doesn't relieve stress but it
definitely
smells of a business that's run by
stoners
yeah i know
duke isn't taking any responsibility for
the lodge
hopefully his brother will have a better
excuse for not sharing any profits with
his mum
gordon wants to meet you
hello hello dusty dusty uh lucky dusty
by the sounds of things oh yes of course
oh i would say hello hi
come here
right yes okay great i'm a very hard
worker
i think gordon's going to like me
uh so are you making money here yes sir
how much money did you make a month uh
last month they made about 12 000. wow
so you make about 150 grand a year uh
with everything working right yeah and
you don't pay a dollar profit to your
mother
private excuse me
the business is a million dollars in
debt you make a shitload of money and
your mum gets nothing
i was shocked that dusty makes that much
and that bothers me because he should
help me out financially known for well
that you stand to inherit this business
there's still not a penny that goes in
to reducing debt and this is your mother
correct
i really devoted my life to this place
and to be treated like i don't care
about my family and don't care about
this business it really cut to the core
i have no problem telling him to get the
[ __ ] out of here i'll give you a kick
with the ass if that was my son
i don't understand why the boys are just
in it for themselves why can't the
business work as one and everybody
pulled together
[Music]
well you haven't done a damn thing
around here i work hard here and i don't
see you do [ __ ] things because you
can't take any criticism without wanting
to punch my [ __ ] lights out
incredible guys how do you feel about
this shut the [ __ ] up both of you him he
hates me listen what would you like me
to do i want to see you grow up and turn
into a real man i want to see you oh
like you're a [ __ ] i want to ha i
want to see you be able to go and call
it
my god no wonder this place is on its
knees [ __ ] you
i'm at oregon's applegate lodge and i
thought the answer for saving this place
was for everyone to work together you
can't take any criticism without wanting
to punch my [ __ ] lights out but the
boys can't even talk to each other
this guy tells me
my [ __ ] brother
is clearly not just the lodge that's
falling apart
[ __ ] you
my god
people have heard about my visit and
both the hotel and restaurant are booked
for the night right this way guys i feel
sorry for all of them hi there come on
over here i'll check you in how you
folks doing tonight and i'm sorry about
the furniture in the lobby they haven't
got any
please take a seat on the stairs the
guests don't look impressed with the
hotel and neither do the customers in
the restaurant but at least they've got
furniture to sit on you shout out here
guys oh [ __ ] that's right rush out of
here for you guys
oh man okay fire up you got you tri-tip
i'm not looking forward to going to
dinner service with gordon um the
interaction i had with him beforehand
i just know it's gonna be a nightmare
every okay with it
this super's pretty cold and it didn't
have a result and then
just water and potatoes
my apologies
potatoes here that is firing off guys
and we got cream pore strawberries
coming right out guys
uh dog at the table is that normal there
the dog does it sit there like that in
front of customers yes sir someone
request them to stay some call them over
yes some customers call the dog over oh
yes of course the food's that bad
while i'm trying to figure out what's
wrong in the restaurant guests in the
hotel are enjoying the unique charm of
the applegate lodge
with the goober of some kind here you
know look at this you got your dry
cleaner hangers i just don't know about
the bear though i mean that's kind of oh
my gosh
where's the tv
i hope the restaurant's better than the
rooms
cam i need that thousand island that
goes with this one here um ketchup
okay we gotta catch up to a ranch and
that'll be a thousand right here okay
what was that ketchup in the side yeah
i can't believe this restaurant is
making money the guests must be coming
for the view because the food is
dreadful
this is grilled salmon with pepper but
it tastes like you literally just
sprinkled it with sugar the salmon is
frozen i'll be more than happy to i'll
just take that off here now certainly i
can't stand to watch another minute of
this thank goodness dinner service is
almost over because this place is a joke
oh dear
got two minutes
i'm embarrassed
i'm amazed you're still open
there's no [ __ ] standards in here i
don't believe that there's no standards
you've got a river running outside your
patio with salmon in it and you're
serving frozen salmon where's the
standard then what we do here is not
[ __ ] you may be able to manipulate your
mother
but you are not going to pull the wool
over myers
because you're playing at ronald reagan
that's been given to you
you haven't actually worked for this
have you you grew up here so hey mom i
want to be a restauranteur this week
without your mother in this lodge
you're [ __ ]
it's nearly 10 o'clock where many hotel
guests will be thinking of heading to
bed but the music concert is just about
to start we've been doing this for 20
years we've been playing music i think
gordon's gonna like
[Music]
i don't do drugs so i never thought i'd
see a dancing mushroom but i was wrong
[Music]
it's like the summer of love these
people are weird but they sure are
friendly
[Music]
is this a dream is this really happening
so are you checking in i am so sorry
welcome to the [ __ ] mad house your
room is uh up these long stairs right
behind you here
it's insane how guests are trying to
check in over this racket if i had
arrived to this i would have gotten on
the first plane back home
i don't think i'll be able to relax here
i can't really escape the sound
wow and the longer the music goes on the
more guests complaining
[Music]
you know what
it's on me tonight okay we're gonna make
you happy no matter what okay okay all
right
with joanna giving away rooms for free
the lodge is losing money pushing this
hotel further into debt
hey thank you guys so much for being a
part of this how about it one more time
for polyrhythmics
it's way past midnight and with the band
finally wrapping up it's time for me to
get some sleep before i dive under those
covers i'm dying to see what's on top of
them
that is disgusting i am not putting my
head on that pillow
oh i just touched that
it's like a mosaic
of semen
look at that
disgusting oh look at the lamb shade and
look at that how can they charge money
for people to sleep in this filth
wow
this is definitely a night
for my sleeping bag
right nice out
[Music]
oh come on it's like trying to sleep
above a nightclub
oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] i'm gonna jump out the window
this is crazy
oh for god's sake
[Music]
[Applause]
it's my first night at oregon's
applegate lodge and there's no way i can
sleep over this dreadful noise i've had
enough
[Applause]
hey gordon i'll be doing it yeah no i'm
trying to get the sleep up there you got
two seconds yeah joe thank you
this is insane oh my god thank you
um how on earth is anyone supposed to
sleep with that racket
[Applause]
can you get the family together yeah
yeah and can we just have a
a meeting together
holy [ __ ]
i don't know what to say i'm i'm i'm
struggling i've never seen anything
quite as shoddy as i've experienced
today and i i i'm wondering why this
place is still open
how much money do we make tonight how
much money did you make about fifteen
hundred bucks fifteen hundred how much
money did you make tonight
uh a couple hundred couple of hundred
about five hundred but with all the
noise complaints joanna had to comp
three rooms isn't that right absolutely
you do make a profit but your mother
loses money
it does not make sense nobody said we
were sensible people
oh we're just blessed people having a
million dollars in debt is not blessed
first of all you don't understand what
you're talking about you're talking
business
you're a businessman where's the
business i'm not a businessman and i
don't try to teach people to be business
people it's this is our home
no one knows the difference between a
hotel and the home
and does anyone else know how much
stress and pressure under um you know i
do what i have to do to keep the doors
open you know can we just quit talking
about money richard why can't it be
financially secure so that both we are
financially no richer we are not you can
laugh at this and laugh at that and we
just want to make everybody happy man it
ain't an issue with me you're refusing
to look at the issue because you and
your sons are taking advantage of joanna
no it's not an issue so why are you
talking so much [ __ ] it's not
[ __ ] it's straight up
everything you say to me i'm just
ignored i'm gonna knock him on his house
you think i care what you think about me
richard
why don't you go have your cigarette
i'll grab my cigarette relax a little
bit and then we'll come back and then
discuss this
i'm not going to argue with your father
i'm just going to call it as i say it
this lodge needs to be run by a business
and when i listen to your mum stressing
out about payments and you two
going off running your own little
businesses because you two are button
heads
it's a [ __ ] disgrace
this [ __ ] has to stop
because right now
this lady's suffering
yet your heads are so far in the [ __ ]
sand
that no one can actually see the damage
you're causing
my worst nightmare is that duke and
dusty never can get on the right page
and
and i'm stuck till i'm 90 years old
trying to run this place and then i die
and it's gone i'm not a miracle worker
if you want this place to survive you
need to come together as a family and
run this place as a proper family
business
it is way past everybody's bedtime i see
in the morning good night
[Music]
this place is insane i mean
i've never seen such a badly run lodge
in all my life and the one person i feel
sorry for is joanna everybody else
they think it's a big joke i'll tell you
what i'm not [ __ ] laughing
[Music]
with all the partying going on at this
lodge i hardly got a wink of sleep
this lodge is in a dreadful state and i
think everyone's blind to it
that has to change
you okay
yeah
uh there's something i want you to
understand because i think the only one
who can actually
appreciate
some things that's been going on here
yeah yeah would you come up with me what
he might be showing me next i don't know
how much worse it could get
hello everybody
uh thank you so much for coming this is
joanna she is the owner
um these are steam guests that have been
staying in your lodge
i need to hear the truth and
so does joanna let's start off with you
madam please um me and my boyfriend
stayed here a few days ago both of us
weren't really pleased we were all the
way in the myrtle suite so we were the
closest to the bar and we could hear it
like we were next to it uh my apologies
uh i'm sorry
please madam sir we got the honeymoon
suite and the bathroom wasn't clean so
we you know i cleaned it and
it just kind of grossed us out the fact
you had to clean the room before you
tried to relax it's insane
adam please we got into bed and felt
something i pulled it up with my foot
and it was a pair of underwear dirty
underwear oh my god
i am mortified that is completely
unacceptable did you have any
interactions with richard
richard invited us to the back room what
in the like the but
yes
it's too old there was marijuana in the
back
he offered which we did not
partake
taking
guests into the
butt room and
offered them
marijuana it's not a hippie community
it's a lodge i know
i thank you for your time
the guest feedback has hit joanna hard
and now she's asked to speak to me alone
are you okay
well i wanted to show you this book
it's the building of the lodge and kind
of see what we went through oh wow from
the beginning from the beginning yeah
wow
we built it with our hands we fell the
trees we hand peeled the poles we did it
all and it's it's an amazing story how
we pulled this together i think if you
understand
the struggle that we went through to get
it to this place you understand why i'm
so
fired up about keeping it and
and having it run wow
top notch and this is this is sort of
ground zero that's right yeah that's
ground zero yeah that's that's the butt
head actually seriously that's
incredible and the kids you know they
were all here we grew up here they're
they're attached to it it means so much
to them
now i understand i mean it's clearly
your
your little paradise but i don't think
it's been paradise for guests but that's
all going to change yep
wow look at that and they lived happily
ever after that was my dream and i think
that could still happen it is going to
happen please yeah
let's go and do this okay you bet i'll
see you shortly okay thank you for that
sure now i can see why joanna loves this
lodge so much and i know that to save
this place i need to get her sons
talking again clearly their dad's not
gonna make that happen
he's too busy doing nothing come here so
i've got to find a way to get these
brothers on the same page
so
can you guys get this thing settled once
and for all i can't talk to him though
and have him not want to punch me
okay i've been being bullied my whole
life gordon what are you talking about
you you really think that you haven't
done anything no what have i tell me
tell me what i've done tell me what i've
said to you that hurts you so bad cause
you've said so many things to me you've
resented me you've told me i'm a punk
you said i'm a white trash tweaker
you're living like one i'm ashamed that
you're my brother
that's a serious statement
[ __ ] come on
this is horrifying you know god just
leave no get the [ __ ] off this property
did you guys get along ever was there
ever a time
[Music]
yet
this is horrifying you know go ahead
just leave no
did you guys get along ever get the [ __ ]
off this spring
when is somebody gonna say
[ __ ] it this isn't about my big brother
my little brother this is about my mum
[Music]
all right the hatred has to stop
i agree the hatred has to stop
yeah
if we don't figure this out we're going
to lose the lodge
i don't want that at all
dusty
why have we let this go on for so long
and i love you and and i
don't want to see you hurt ever
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
it's been such a long road with duke
that you know i've just been been
praying every day for something to
change because it taxes my mother so
much
i am so relieved to hear that from both
of you you okay yeah
[Music]
now that duke and dusty have seen the
pain they've caused their mother i
believe they're gonna be willing to put
their issues aside to save this piece of
paradise
this lodge has so much potential in this
beautiful setting
[Music]
it's somewhere i'd love to bring my wife
and four kids for a vacation
it would be a tragedy if joanna and her
family lost it
what an absolutely beautiful place to go
for a swim
but there's still one problem i need to
tackle to make sure this lodge has a
future it deserves
it's time to talk business
take a seat
um richard
there's a business meeting okay you're
not really involved running the business
right okay and i think you
need to let these guys deal with the
business so i would ask you
to disappear
you're a nice guy you're not going to
change and you know what i don't think
your family want you to change i love
you yeah as you are yes okay so i want
you to have a relaxed afternoon cool
thank you that's why you're here well i
appreciate i've been talking years you
take care
okay okay see that thank you richard
right now it's not your time young man
and it's not your time jo who's time it
is
that's right
that's right and she's at the helm
but she can't do without you that's
right
all the personal [ __ ] you leave when you
walk through that door because it's
about business now yeah we've never had
that
you have the possibility of turning this
around
joanna what have you got to say i just
really need you guys both
you know i tried for many years to do
this on my own
but you know what it's time maybe you
guys help out a little more
let's get this thing going man let's
roll you realize how freaking lucky we
are to have this place
boys
are both of you committed to working
together and getting this place turned
around
yeah i'm in and if you're in it
absolutely man
as businessmen and then brothers
hopefully figure this out we'll work the
other [ __ ] out
here for a moment okay
okay all right
it just warms my heart to watch the boys
embrace and and to see that they really
want to to work together and to help
grow this place again
it feels like a waste been lifted off my
shoulders right now and now that we're
actually on some sort of
a page together i think we can we can
really start going somewhere with it i
am just like stoked
these are tears of joy not sorrow thank
god there's a lot more changes coming
tomorrow thank you joanna thank you
i thought gordon was coming here to fix
the lodge but he ended up fixing our
family which is amazing
thank you thank you i'll see you later
okay
welcome to the new
applegate river lodge from this day
forward we will run this
as one business
yes
there's a restaurant yes
it's a music venue but they are all part
of the lodge business and they
contribute to the overall lodge finances
understood understood good i cannot wait
for you to see
through those doors you ready yeah let's
go
[Music]
whoa
oh my god oh my gosh wow
oh nice
wow holy smokes
this looks like a lodge wow
oh my god
when i first got here i had to sit on
the floor now your guests will feel warm
and very welcomed yes absolutely wow the
lobby actually feels like a lobby now
the leather couch is incredible and
rocking chairs i mean people can come
down in the morning have a cup of coffee
they can sit down
it's amazing
is it gorgeous it's beautiful yeah i
love it come over the reception desk
there's something else i want to show
you
here is the magic
ooh
oh yeah i have given you a stunning
brand new hotel management pos point of
sale system
so now your guests can check in online
wow it works in here
it works in the restaurant and it's
going to tap in to your music as well
perfectly i love it that system is going
to really change everything we do here
gordon has just he synced everything up
and made this one business it's really
what this place has needed for so long
now would you like to see my room yes
absolutely let's go
there we go go straight through
[Music]
oh cute look at this
wonderful oh it's gorgeous oh nice
oh it smells so good in here too i love
it wow so the room is fresh it's vibrant
it's warm and i've had all the carpets
cleaned so there are no more stains ooh
nice
my curtains are gone my 16 year old
curtains
it's nice is it beautiful we're nice
they're disgusting bedware all gone and
with the blinds guests no longer need to
stare down a rich's butthole
the cattleman room looks like a really
classy place now i mean the bed
the furnishings the lamps it's
it's not all that funky stuff i had in
there for years
oh i love it stunning one last thing i'd
like to show you at the restaurant are
you ready yep yep let's go we've got
some exciting things happening there
[Music]
oh my welcome to the new applegate river
lodge a menu the menu small the menu's
dynamic and the better the ingredients
the less that needs doing to them let's
start off with the top shall we half a
roasted chicken and a lovely sage lemon
butter sauce next to that the wild king
salmon with citronelle and grilled lemon
and then finally 12
new york strip stunning i like it it's
simple but it's it's perfect now sit
down and enjoy
oh my god
[Music]
you can just taste the freshness it's
really good it's a night and day
i love this menu because it's us have we
ever had dinner all together
it really hasn't happened yeah
with the davis family ready to work
together
and the stunning new changes to the
lodge i've got one more surprise for the
family that will take this hotel to a
whole new level
this one you're going to love
oh that's so
cool now
this is everything you need to put on a
mini
music festival for your guests
oh i can't believe it
here's the exciting news all of a sudden
the lodge has four extra bedrooms no way
oh no oh my gosh
oh wow yeah that's too good
wow
coupled with a new outdoor grill so the
guests can enjoy a phenomenal barbecue
lunch while they enjoy the show
now the music business the lodge of the
restaurant will work together and all
the elements of the business will be
making money to help pay down the debt
and keep this place open for decades to
come i'm completely excited and ready to
start doing music outdoors and i think
it's really going to be a great way for
the lodge and the restaurant and the
music to unite wow
now richard you will not believe what
i've done with your butt hut you ready
only joking i haven't touched that thing
you don't want to go in there
[Music]
it's time for the new and improved
applegate lodge to open to the public
[Music]
while dusty and camin deal with the
meals duke and melissa handle the
entertainment with their combined effort
much needed revenue is coming into the
lodge and with the music on the outdoor
stage the entertainment is far enough
away for guests to enjoy their rooms
quiet
feels like we're away from everything
now that the relaunch is a success i've
got to hit the road
gordon it's time to say goodbye there's
been a slice of heaven a little slice of
heaven
serious yeah but please do not offer any
more guests some of those special herbs
are ready you built this place right now
let them have it or
gladly take care of them it's been an
absolute pleasure
[Music]
boys my time is done look after each
other
and forget the past work with your
brother and take some weight off your
mother's shoulders yeah and this place
is gonna roll thank you so much gordon
if gordon didn't come we'd we'd be in
the same stagnant environment with uh no
love and a lot of anger those boys need
to know who's boss they will uh good
luck thank you so much okay
there's just no words that can express
how grateful i feel for this awesome
amazing experience good night
bye-bye
i'll be sad to leave this place
but i will not be sorry to see the back
of richard's butthole
[Music]
since my visit to the applegate river
lodge dusty and duke continue to get
along and they're helping joanna get
income for the lodge to reduce their
debt if you want to get all the trash
i'll get all the dishes uh okay this
family-run hotel is finally running
smoothly
i feel like this is the first step to
taking the lodge into a destination
resort which is what it needs to be we
should spend more time together as a
family you know yeah
gordon has given us an opportunity of a
lifetime and we're not going to let him
down
i want to thank gordon
for having the love in his heart to come
here
and put my family back together
[Music]
that's what i wanted
love you thank you
you